you
it is great to be with you all today
wonderful to be back on campus I've been
on your side of the podium I think it's
been a long time since I've been in this
room both when I was in your shoes a
little bit excited a little bit anxious
about what the next steps might be as I
got those coveted letters MBA as Garth
kindly pointed out my education Stanford
opened doors for me they have
opportunities at a number of major
companies but I would also say as I look
back the story is not as neat as it
sounds in the resume and I've
encountered just as believe all of you
will bumps and bruises along the way
twists and turns that certainly
challenged me challenged my resolve and
navigating those twists and turns that
come a long way is a big part of our
collective challenge I love my work with
habitat and feel greatly privileged to
get to be a part of this mission and as
I look back I can see how all the
different experiences along the way
helped prepare me even if I couldn't see
it at the time I certainly don't pretend
to have all the answers as to what makes
a great leader but I can share a little
bit of what I've observed your
experiences your choices are going to
determine your individual journeys but I
hope you can benefit from a little of
what I've seen from both the roles and
some of the people I've had a chance to
observe along the way like you I've read
books on leadership and collected my
share of quotes that inspire me among
those is equipped by a leadership expert
and author John Maxwell who offers this
tongue-in-cheek word of encouragement
when you're getting discouraged as a
leader said John think of Moses he led a
million complaining people for 40 years
in the desert and never arrived where he
was supposed to get Moses faced a lot of
complaints criticism and just plain
whining some days as a leader I can
sympathize with Moses I bet if you had
to do it all over again make a note to
self next time don't tell Pharaoh let
all my people go
you know leadership's hard I think the
more people you you attempt to lead the
harder it gets and Moses is a good
example and as garthe laid the
groundwork I'm gonna share today in the
context of my personal faith and because
my story doesn't really make sense
without that but I hope regardless of
your own faith perspectives that the
principles behind it will will resonate
with you today one of the first lessons
I'd like to offer around leadership is a
common sense one is the importance of
role models and I think all successful
leaders identify either individuals or
some compositive individuals that they
want to emulate and they may be great
bosses teachers counselors parents in my
case I was blessed both with a mother
who had a ferocious sense of justice and
was very active in the civil rights
movement and a rather formidable
grandmother a woman named Millicent
Fenwick who was a civil and human rights
pioneer and New Jersey congresswoman who
encouraged me and my siblings at a early
age to think about what we're gonna do
to serve the lost and left out in the
world or in her words to be useful
Walter Cronkite later called her the
conscience of Congress I don't know how
many of you read the comic strip
Doonesbury
yeah my grandma's often referred to as
the model for Garry Trudeau's character
Lacey Davenport in the dunes Barry
strips and she had a rather imposing
regal presence and prior to her public
career she had the unusual distinction
of having written the Vogue book of
etiquette which sold a million copies in
1948 and so in order to graduate to the
grown-up table at Grandma's house you
had to be able to sit up straight and
hold your fork properly and discuss food
problems in sub-saharan Africa which was
both fascinating and terrifying as a
young child and she was intimidating but
was also spiritual at her core and
almost every time I would see her she at
some point drill in and quote Micah six
six through eight from the Bible he has
shown you O man what is good and what
does the Lord require of you but to act
justly to love mercy
to walk humbly with your God so act
justly love mercy and walk humbly with
your God pretty good marching orders for
most of us and that's become my life
verse as well though it took a long time
to grow into that I didn't come to
Stanford right after college my original
plan of going into law going to law
school then into politics got derailed
when I realized I had no actual interest
in practicing law so I had to come up
with Plan B and talk my way into a job
at Goldman Sachs and despite the the
latest images this is a tough month for
that company one of the most important
lessons I learned early was one was from
one of the co-leaders of Goldman at that
time a man named John Weinberg and there
were a lot of less senior people in the
firm who were caught up in their own
power and and but John Weinberg took a
personal interest in virtually everyone
and he had a deep personal respect for
everybody in the firm and that's been
something it's been critical to me to
watch both for people I was going to
potentially work with or for or also now
when I'm hiring people to see you know
how do they behave towards the
receptionist to the custodian or people
that don't have potential in positive
influence for them as a sign of
character and not everyone will agree
but to me as a core tenet of leadership
is that fundamental respect for all
people in organizations I wasn't a great
fit as a financial analyst I was a
poli-sci English major with no
accounting or finance preparation and
had to suffer hard to to live up to the
idea I'd sold myself the idea I could
learn finance faster than could teach
someone to communicate I'm not sure it
was totally true and I found it really
intellectually interesting but not very
emotionally satisfying and was living in
New York City in Times Square and sort
of juxtaposition of walking past these
huge numbers of homeless people every
morning and evening against the sort of
big mergers and acquisitions and
financing deals that caused me to do
some hard thinking and I also had a
growing sense of a disconnect between
the life I'd imagined living and the way
I was actually spending my time
at that point and so felt I'd become
really interested in business along the
way but felt it needed to go off and
have an adventure and was lucky enough
to get the loose program and the you
know to put the coaching in perspective
they only qualified because they were
the host team and it's there were some
parallels to the Jamaican bobsled team
but we did beat the Japanese so for
those of you who know Asia there was
significant and it was a it was a huge
life experience for me as an immersion
experience I was living in the Korean
training camp with all the coaches and
athletes and the only other non Korean I
got to see was a Russian boxing coach
who was also in the dormitory and is
sort of unfathomable most of you a world
with no internet no email and
staggeringly expensive phone calls so
really quite isolated from from all my
relationships and so it gave me a lot of
time to read and think and reflect and
the only Westerner I saw on a regular
basis was a man named Jim Peterson who
was the other loose scholar that haven't
placed in Korea that year and he was a
pastor and ethics professor teaching at
one of the great Korean universities and
Jim was one of those rare people who had
both the intellectual rigor to go as
deep as I could go theologically and at
the same time which really caught my
attention and inner peace and a quiet
confidence that really contrasted I
think to my sort of raw ambition and
need to impress people and Jim took the
time to get to know me and then made
really a quite extraordinary offer he
offered me the all of his Monday nights
for the rest of that year and we ended
up spending three to five hours every
Monday night walking through the Bible
and doing systematic theology so I got
my private seminary and I think for some
people I knew all of your own
experiences faith can be a sort of
burning bush event less so for me I had
to have that integration of head and
heart so it was a very gradual process
that eventually got me to what searing
søren kierkegaard calls that leap of
faith but it was finally it became clear
to me that the kind of life I wanted to
lead was one of faith and and that was
1987 and I think for me hasn't
necessarily made life easier but
for me has made life better and richer
and so as my time at Korea was coming to
an end I applied to business schools
with the thought and Stanford was the
cutting edge of this that the skills I
could acquire in the business world were
desperately needed in the nonprofit and
service world as well and Stanford was
very intriguing to me because the public
management program is integrated into
the regular business curriculum it while
at Stanford I got interested in business
strategy and how organizations grow and
after graduation can to choose your job
criteria my most important criterion was
to get to Washington DC where my then
girlfriend now wife Ashley was so had
the chance to work with Marriott working
on new business development and their
strategic planning group and had a
chance to was enjoying it very much
helped work on the launch of their
senior living services their adult adult
care business and got married got
promoted life was good and then the
though it pales in comparison that the
S&L crisis hit so for those of you
historians was not a great not as bad as
now but was not a great time for the
financial world mary had actually nearly
went bankrupt and made significant cuts
that included our strategic planning
team and me and it was little shocking
to be laid off I was newly married and
I'd lost my job and even though I was
sort of perfectly explicable it wasn't
it was hard not to feel a little bit
rejected and turned out fine I was had
the chance to start up a strategic
planning group for the real estate arm
of Disney which was a really fun and
interesting experience got to work on
great projects and I think Disney taught
me a lot about being a fanatic about
great customer service which I really
appreciate but there was another side of
Disney which I appreciate a little less
and that was sort of the Burbank studio
culture at the time and one of the
former execs I won't name was was very
well known and behaved for quotes like
this if you don't come in on Saturday
don't bother coming in on Sunday or
or a little more frightening though
humorous other cutter companies do good
cop bad cop we do bad cop Antichrist and
it was not good to apologize the
beginning of any negotiation with an
outside party for the inherent
unreasonableness of our position but it
is it leads to two lesson number three
which is you have to be very careful
about becoming a leader or working in a
place that doesn't operate in sync with
your personal values and I mean obsessed
starts with having to know your personal
values and as I was sort of struggling
with the implications of this and sort
of what kind of career I could have
their headhunter called with an
opportunity to come to Circuit City and
there's correlation but not causality at
least two of the companies I work for
don't exist anymore but Circuit City was
on top of the world actually then they'd
been the fastest-growing stock on New
York Stock Exchange for the entire 1980s
and they just started Carmack's I don't
have any proof amilia but it was they
actually revolutionized the used-car
business and was the first time anyone
had ever offered warrantied fixed price
returnable used cars and I thought that
was really interesting so we moved to
Richmond Virginia and I never intended
to be in retail but found the work
really interesting learned a lot that
had had a growing condense it had a
growing desired actually to run
something at this point and I've been
doing lots of business development work
and so after four years phone rang again
and quite unexpected and this was music
land which is about a two billion dollar
retailer at the time back when people
actually bought music and movies on
plastic discs which is another thing
it's hard to believe and we were we were
the leading mall retailer of
entertainment products and that has a
disappearing category and Napster had
just launched so they could see the
future and offer me the chance to run
the operations and help navigate a new
path for the company I can't say my wife
was terribly enthused and why God would
want us nice southern lady to move to
Minneapolis the land of and
winter and but but I had a very strong
sense it was what we were supposed to do
and she she grudgingly agreed and so we
made the move actually had a couple of
record years and yet one of the more
discouraging things from business
perspective it was very hard to see how
the company could survive not just
against the brick-and-mortar but against
the inevitable digital transformation
that was coming so we ended up selling
the company to Best Buy which was a
great win for our shareholders and a
great loss for really are ultimately for
our staff and for Best Buy it was not a
great acquisition and I stayed for a
year to help try to make the acquisition
work but also then became clear that
that I was redundant with the
appropriately put in Best Buy head of
the division and so Best Buy was kind
enough to offer some different
opportunities but I'd had a growing
sense that maybe it was time and it
taken much long and I expected maybe
this was the time to begin the
transition that I'd always plan to the
nonprofit world and I'd been
increasingly passionate about some of
them my volunteer work which had been
helping coach pastors and priests in the
leadership side of churches and so even
though I regularly counsel people don't
ever leave without knowing what your
next step is in this case made the
decision to jump and took off with some
big ideas and a fairly ferocious
non-compete clause but I did have a
walkway package that was not a very
brave particularly brave move and for us
the freedom meant I was going to have a
huge amount of time with at that point
our very young children and at home with
Ashley and time to have a little space
to sort of really think about the next
step and a little while after that
actually encouraged me to do something
I'd never had time to do and always want
to do which was to go on international
mission trip and I know many of you have
done this now or service trip I'd wanted
to go to Uganda where our church had
been sponsoring all the AIDS orphans in
the rock I district where where AIDS
really broke out but I was too late to
join that trip and ended up through a
series of events being able to join an
opportunity to serve with the Dalits in
in Central India and the Bunge even
among the Dalits commonly known the
untouchables are the traditional
outcasts in Indian community and the
Bunge are the sort of bottom of the
bottom of the social pecking order
literally only allowed to hand clean
latrines and clean up after dead animals
and living in conditions that really are
unimaginably bad and about half the kids
without some sort of intervention
they're dying by the age of 13 from a
combination of poor nutrition and poor
health and I think for me just shattered
me too
to see people living in these conditions
and it was I don't know that I knew but
I essentially after a couple of weeks
there came back with a pretty strong
sense that I was it was time to spend
the rest of my time doing something to
help the poor and I think for me it
really passions around social justice
that had softened down a little bit over
the years is what Bill Hybels Pastor
Willow Creek church calls a holy
discontent that was a nicely turn phrase
and we have plenty of discontent in our
society and I see that all over the
place people are watching some terrible
event unfold in their community of the
world and responses that's terrible
somebody ought to do something about
that and then they change channels and
watch American Idol and a holy
discontent in contrast is when you are I
see those same terrible events unfold in
our community in the world the responses
I can't stand that and I'm gonna do
something about it and you turn off the
TV and get off the couch and get out
into the community and decide to be
making try to make the world a little
bit better it's so I came back with a
new passion but not a very clear
direction and what was little took me
back was for the first time really in my
whole life suddenly all the doors were
closing and now I can look back and see
why none of those were the right things
but got to the finals of a couple of
different really exciting nonprofit jobs
and didn't get them and I think we MBAs
are particularly at risk of defining
ourselves by what we do so when people
would ask the inevitable question I had
a sort of a matter of discipline to
spite my tongue and resist the urge
I used to be XYZ or I used to do XYZ and
just say that you know I was home with
my family and trying to figure out what
I was supposed to do next and I'm not a
particularly patient person so I didn't
waiting isn't very easy for me and I
think when you wait and question it can
it can drive you a little bit nuts for
us type-a types and when I'd first left
BestBuy turned down some very good
business jobs then I started wondering
you know did I get the signals wrong did
I did I miss miss the opportunity and in
the meantime I was cranking way up on my
volunteer time both with our kids and at
their school and at church and quite
unexpectedly the all the leadership
development work I was doing at our very
large church ended up with the church
asking me to come and run the church as
executive pastor to free up the senior
pastor just to teach and preach and it
was not what I was looking to do and
most of my friends thought this was a
really bad career move and would not be
a smart thing to do but his best we
could tell best I could tell it was what
I was supposed to do so went into
full-time Church work and in fact loved
it and it was a great time for our
family and it was it was a very
fulfilling time for me and I was not
actually looking when probably the most
important phone call I've gotten came in
and it was from a partner at Spencer
Stewart who had recruited me in the past
who asked Jonathan do you know anybody
who'd be interested in CEO for Habitat
for Humanity and Jill went down my spine
and I asked a little bit shyly does it
have to be somebody famous and and then
went home and wrote a very passionate
letter about why this was the kind of
thing I had been preparing for for the
last many years and I felt like finally
here was something that really combined
all of my passions and and put
everything together it was for me very
much my dream job and I really wanted it
very badly did not expect to get it and
was very surprised and delighted to have
the chance and I it's a lot of detail
but
I share that because the fourth lesson I
would share is you know my dad was a
teacher and he taught in one place for
forty five years and then retired I
think that world has changed I think in
the business world especially careers
are enormous ly more fluid than they
used to be and what I would encourage
you is to is to not fight those detours
along the way and particularly to take
advantage of the learning from the white
spaces in your in your career and the
failures which I often found were the
richest learning times for me I arrived
at a really critical inflection point
for habitat in many ways like like very
successful startup companies they were
in the process of transitioning from a
highly charismatic entrepreneurial
founder and had grown far bigger than
they'd ever imagined and needed in the
board's view more professional
management and to build out a sort of
infrastructure and leadership team to
support this exponential growth that
they'd had around the world habitat
needed to become more efficient more
sustainable and more equipped to be able
to continue to sustain the growth given
how much the size of the need in
virtually every country in which we
serve I think many of you I presume
almost everyone's familiar with habitat
but let me give you just a quick habitat
101 class most importantly we build
houses in partnership with not for
families who need simple decent and
affordable homes in the US and across
the world we don't give the houses away
homeowners make a down payment and
purchase their homes from us on a no
profit basis homeowners are selected
based on three core criteria first need
there wouldn't be otherwise able to
obtain a home loan or mortgage second
the ability to repay a very affordable
no profit mortgage over 15 to 30 year
period and third the willingness to
partner with habitat and for us what
partnering means is willingness to put
hundreds of hours of sweat equity into
building their home and helping build
other people's homes and also to go
through financial and home management
training and preparation for
homeownership in the same way than their
mortgage payments revolve in the
community so that in addition to being
recipients they become donors to help
other families have a chance at
homeownership as a Christian ministry
now working into our fourth deck
we've got a pretty good idea of what to
expect when a family gets for the first
time a decent place to live we see huge
impacts on health that children grow up
and growing up in decent homes have much
better health outcomes healthy children
have much better educational outcomes
and in addition to the sort of physical
and material benefits of home ownership
there's a huge psychological change that
happens as well when people have a place
to call home and what we've seen over
and over again our family members are so
proud of their new houses their homes
become social centers they become
anchors in the community to stabilize
communities and many communities have
been lifted from forgotten blighted
areas to areas that have been restored
and become inviting neighborhoods in
fact now with the housing crisis
purchasing up these empty foreclosed
homes has become a high priority for us
so we're shifting our mix more away from
new home construction towards rehabbing
empty homes and in that and around those
rehabbed homes tearing down the worst
ones building targeted new ones and then
doing weatherization and repairs to help
preserve homeownership for especially
for the elderly in those communities and
in that trying to do as much as we can
to revitalize whole communities versus
individual homes
that's the habitat model it's a model
that's been effective for now for well
over 30 years as Garth said last year we
helped over 61 thousand families through
a mix of new homes and rehabs and major
repairs which is almost triple where we
were five years ago have the nonprofit
world is at least as complex from a
management perspective as anything I
found in the business world we have over
1500 affiliates in the US which goes
back to that Moses quote and I think the
once had a report in New York Times say
that this big change we were putting in
had caused 12 affiliates to get upset
and I just laughed I thought if there
was anything we ever did that only
twelve affiliates were upset at we would
be doing hallelujahs but when you add
all that together were actually the
largest private home builder in the
United States we serve in over 80
countries
if you hydrate all of the habitat
budgets together it's about a billion
and a half in terms of total revenue and
we increasingly are able to play a
significant role in terms of shaping
housing policies around the world as
well
Stanford stood for the idea all the way
back to Ernie Arbuckle that the same
skills that will make you successful in
the for-profit world are needed in the
nonprofit world and I took that
seriously but I can tell you it is it is
more true than ever now and I think it's
a much more widely accepted idea now as
well I know certainly we're being called
to use those skills we've set a new goal
at habitat now to serve a hundred
thousand families per year by 2013 which
was going to challenge us to continue to
find new ways to scale up an increase in
our impact in the communities in which
we serve and I feel very blessed to have
a small role in that process I have the
the sad part of my job as I continue to
travel across the world to places and
see the way the families live all across
the world and it is truly heartbreaking
still and and you know the numbers but
I've also had the chance to see what
just as we call a hand up not a hand out
can do to to let a family lift
themselves out of poverty and the
fundamental difference that can make in
life last year I looked into the eyes of
a six year old girl in small town in El
Salvador who told me her dreams of being
a lawyer so she could help others her
mother was already living her dream
she'd always wanted to be a hairdresser
and have her own salon but had never had
the chance and now she'd open a salon in
her new habitat home and as soon as the
girls who can now go to school went off
she started treating customers and she's
able to earn an income and spend the
time with her girls in Vietnam last fall
I met a family 51 year old grandfather
who had literally spent his entire life
living on a boat with his extended
family and we we have the privilege of
tucking our children into bed they would
tie the children in at night because
they lost one grandchild to drowning in
bad weather and if you could see the
boat or the boats these families were
living in it would just it would just
break your heart and I had the privilege
of dedicating with them we talked about
a house being the foundation for a
decent life those family for the first
time ever was going to have a foundation
and live on dry land which meant their
kids can now go to school unbelievable
health impacts
or for them and for their future so my
days don't get much better than that and
quick review the leaders I've respected
the most have emulated good role models
and picked the right ones they respect
and value all of their staff and teams
they find a place that to work that is
in sync with their defined personal
values and they remain adaptable and is
eager to learn from their failures as
their successes I think for me when I
look back on the story my life changed
dramatically for the better during one
of the sort of quiet times in life when
I wasn't earning a dime and probably was
most frustrated and I don't think I
could have ever charted the path that
led to habitat if I was I wouldn't have
been ready for this role if I had come
straight from Best Buy and I also know
that if I take in the job at the church
just so that I could get a job like
habitat I'm fully convinced that never
would have worked it is in my experience
the times that I really loved work when
I was really focused on getting projects
done or or doing something that that
mattered and and the least successful
were those when I was focused on trying
to grow my career and my hope for all of
you is that you'll find the same
satisfaction I hope and pray that each
of you will find a vocation that allows
you to to take your gifts and skills and
passions and do something but in the
private sector or the nonprofit world
that makes the world a little bit better
I think we all get bombarded constantly
and and you all are and will continue to
be bombarded with definitions of the
good life that base everything based on
the size of your salary and the house
you live in the car you drive how much
plastic surgery you've had how perfect
you look and I think it brings me to the
final lesson when as you get increasing
responsibilities in leadership I think
you'll be awash in temptations and I
think you've got to be very intentional
about defining what a good life is for
you and B in pursuing it because the the
lure of letting other people's other
people define that for you is very
tempting and it's very easy for all of
us to get our
goes and identities caught up in our
jobs or intermixed with our jobs and I
find out to be more careful than ever
now that I'm in a comparatively public
position as a son of a classics
professor I think we all need to be very
careful the idea of hubris that idea of
literally putting ourselves on par with
the gods when I see the things that blow
leaders up and usually it's around money
sex and power they're really all wrapped
up in Pride and you have to be aware of
those temptations and I think the ones
who say that could never happen to me
that's often the first step down that
path and I've seen some dear friends and
otherwise really effective and great
leaders totally derail not only their
careers but their families because they
weren't aware of those temptations or
didn't think it could happen to them and
my experience is better to be humble
than to be humbled and I don't think you
have to think of humility as a
limitation Jim Collins who was a GSB
entrepreneurship professor back when we
were here before he became a guru
discovered that idea of a level 5 leader
in his research and I was so pleased to
see that and that idea of people that he
would say paradoxical combination of
personal humility and fierce ambition
for their mission or cause not that
level 5 leaders have no ego or
self-interest in fact they're incredibly
ambitious but it's ambition for what
they're trying to get done rather than
for themselves and tied to that is
integrity which we just see over and
over again can be destroyed in an
instant Warren Bennis another leadership
guru describes effective leadership as a
carefully balanced three-pronged stool
of ambition competence and a moral
compass and sadly we can't watch the
business in these days without seeing
what happens when you have destructive
achievers high ambition high competence
and no moral compass and leadership
ultimately comes starts or emanates from
character and character comes from a
Greek word that literally means a tool
that marks or engraves us and each each
day each choice each action we make
we're in a constant process of either
making or unmaking our character either
moving more towards the kind of person
we want to be or moving back and it's
ultimately how our colleagues and others
are going to measure us so you have to
choose those values you're gonna live by
you've got to choose the lines that
you're not willing to cross before those
situations actually come along and and
finally you've got if you've got a lead
from passion not just from position and
I hope I didn't always know I saw had
lots of passion but very little focus
and I hope you can all find that area of
passion for you what is that that issue
that problem that thing in society that
you look out and upsets you or you think
could be done better or could be fixed
what's your holy discontent and that
might be a the first clue to what your
calling is Frederick Buechner theologian
says calling is where the deep gladness
of your heart
meets the world's great need and I think
it's worth take some reflection to to
put those together but if you can then
you'll be ready when that when the right
phone rings or when that right call
comes so what are your dreams what
problems do you want to solve what price
you're willing to pay to to make that
happen so we close and I hope to turn
into a conversation just want to share
my favorite blessing from the Franciscan
tradition may God bless you would
discomfort at easy answers half-truths
and superficial relationships so you may
live deeply within your heart may God
bless you with anger at injustice
oppression and exploitation of people so
that you may wish for justice freedom
and peace and may God bless you with
enough foolishness to believe that you
can make a difference in this world so
that you can do what others say cannot
be done it's great to be with you thank
you
if we have time for some questions and I
think they asked if people would wait
for the mic to be passed down so they
can capture them so everybody can hear
well thank you for coming I wanted to
ask a question going back to the sale of
music land it seemed like you had some
different constituents there that had
competing interests between shareholders
and your team and maybe even customers
and I was curious how your faith and how
Christian principles informed how you
balance those interests in a particular
was it difficult for you to reconcile
the sale of an asset that it seems like
you had some suspicions was a family an
asset and maybe the sale wouldn't go
well you know I think the interesting
thing was Best Buy had a hypothesis that
turned out to be flawed but they had a
model of using the real estate and the
huge number of relationships we had with
teens in malls to leverage those for
electronic sales and so it was a
plausible strategy of why it was going
to be different than it was going to
migrate away from music and it didn't
work but we we I think we're more they
were way more optimistic and we were
more optimistic at the time that that
was actually the best path because
otherwise we could see sort of a long
eroding tale where we just be closing
stores as leases came up because retail
is you know the leverage is so strong
that relatively small decreases in sales
wipe out all your profitability very
quickly so it's a it's a very thin
business so it but I think it is you
know much easy to look back now with all
the data then then when you're looking
forward but best buy I was on a roll and
they had the financial strength to
underwrite the sort of revamping of the
stores that we didn't have the capital
to do so it was struck us as at the time
as sort of the best option for everybody
though it's you know everybody should go
through a merger being acquired once you
learn it's an incredible education of I
think the danger of almost every
acquisition is even if they're done for
strategic purposes and you acquire
because you want the skills and gifts of
the group you're acquiring there's an ax
jurors bias that I've seen whether I was
in the investment banking side or or in
the operating side where the acquire
tends to think they have all the answers
and so they think best buy made some
major strategic mistakes by not fully
understanding what the assets they were
buying before they put all the changes
in place but it's I think it's a it's a
constant juggling act of all those
stakeholders
well thanks also for coming I think a
lot of times ministry organizations have
a lot of difficulty in the management of
people how they hire how they fire how
they grow many times they can't fire
just out of obligation or out of you
know some can you just kind of talk
about how you've managed habitat if you
see some of those issues when you came
in and how are you gonna grow and build
a business going forward
thank you it's it's a really interesting
challenge I think and actually it was so
that's part of why I'm so valuable and
to work in a church environment before
coming to Habitat which and if you ever
if you want the most complex management
town in some ways try to manage a
synagogue or or mosque or church because
you've got immense ownership all
volunteers very little leverage over the
people doing all the work and and an
enormous shared ownership of the mission
so the great assets but great complexity
as well and what what I found is it was
really helpful learn is you can manage
volunteers and if you can manage
volunteers you can may it's much easier
to manage people but we learned that you
can hold volunteers accountable that you
that actually you need do the same work
to make sure a volunteer is in a role
that he or she is values and uses their
gifts well one of the things that faith
groups do poorly is often they'll take
really high capacity people and put them
in the wrong roles and habitat was doing
the same thing and so the second thing I
learned is that you know it's you're not
you're not doing someone a favor by
letting them sit in the wrong role not
being successful that's bad for the
mission and actually bad for the
individual
and so I was sharing with a group last
night you know I think what I had to
learn was that it has to be integrated I
get pushed you know often as we put in
change and serve significantly raised
accountability that got thrown back as
well you're not being faithful anymore
and that sort of either we were going to
be grassroots and faithful or we were
going to be professional and that was
termed going corporate and that was
viewed as a bad thing and and the
response was no you know we're using
other people's money to do God's work to
serve the poor of the world we should
have much higher standards than the
private sector because the stakes are so
high so we're going to be unapologetic
about accountability and and much of the
practice we do would be standard in any
well-run organization I hope in terms of
making sure everyone has a very clear
roles very clear responsibilities they
know what they're supposed to be
accountable for and that and we reward
them for for doing their work it's um I
think it's hard though because there's
that whole being nice you know if
anybody here from Minnesota so there's
you know they call Minnesota nice so the
land of the land of Lutheran's and Lake
Wobegon where we're you know nobody
wants to say the hard things and I think
part of my view is it's not again you
don't have to be nice or you know bad
cop Antichrist model that there's a that
you can be both nice and and be really
clear and transparent and sometimes
there's a the other thing we see in
non-profit suppose you were think about
nonprofit management is you get two
groups I think in nonprofits one group
who are people with world-class gifts
and skills and talents who are there
because of the mission and I think
there's another group sometimes you were
there you know somewhat as refugees or
to be rescued rather than rather than to
to make a difference and that's really
hard and it is what we found is we want
to treat people respectfully we weren't
treat people well but at the end of the
day the first thing is the mission and
what we can't do is allow somebody who's
not performing well because if you send
a signal that it's okay not to perform
well that starts sort of demotivating
your high-performing folks and pulling
them down but it's not easy
Thanks one of the things I've been most
impressed about is your ability to scale
over the last five years can you talk
about what are some of the levers that
you pulled to be able to do that in the
nonprofit world and what are some of the
challenges that you face going forward
as you look at taking it to the next
level thank you it's you know some
things you know true every organization
and the best ideas are all at the field
level so we certainly didn't come in and
say here all the great new ideas we
actually I traveled around the world and
just looked for what was what was
working or what were all the things
people were secretly doing but didn't
you know weren't saying because they
didn't think that would be okay back at
headquarters and we tried to give
permission to and a couple things
particularly drove growth one right as I
started Katrina head which was not on my
hundred day plan but it freed us up to
break a lot of rules in terms of doing
something we need to do something big by
our standards in in the Gulf so it
forced us to sit down and sort of
reassess the model of how can we do
enough to matter in that in that so we
got the board to formally bless disaster
recovery as a formal part of our work
which had been informally there for a
while and we use the tsunami in Asia and
Katrina in the US as models of scaling
up we end up helping 23,000 families in
the tsunami which was way bigger than
anything we've done and we were the
leading we may still be the leading home
builder in the in the Gulf Coast since
Katrina which again is not a typical
role for Habitat but in doing that we
used that to learn how to move faster
and to do whole community development
and and operate at a scale and operate
in partnership in ways that we hadn't
before
so now Haiti and Chile we're doing we're
gonna try to help 50 thousand families
in Haiti and in a similarly large number
we hope in chile over time so disaster
response was big second one was housing
microfinance and microfinance extremely
well-established but almost almost 90 to
95 percent of people in the world have
no access to a home loan of any kind and
so what we were in addition to all the
so we do housing lending out of
necessity but it's not our preference so
one of our goals is to get the
microfinance world to begin lending
home improvement loans to families that
have been taking out successful small
business loans and we're that's been a
we see that as a huge next scale-up
we're launching a global housing
microfinance fund to be a wholesale
lender to MFIs and then we'll do
technical assistance if they'll do the
lending and that we see that as one of
our next big bridges for scale and then
third one would be around advocacy
trying to actually change policies so we
can impact way more people than the
houses we build and our big focus is on
secure tenure and property rights
especially for women in developing
countries so we're trying to change
rules to crate protections and again if
we can use crises to to do that so we're
doing big projects around HIV widows
Northam programs in Africa particularly
in Southeast Asia in India and the
tsunami we used the so the chance to
come in and serve we title all the homes
along the southeast Indian coast and
women's names only and got the other
nonprofits to do the same thing that
actually had a pretty profound social
change in terms of changing changing the
values there so and in similarly in
Africa in a lot of countries if a
woman's husband dies his family inherits
the property and the widow and children
are left out so we're we're trying to
get laws changed to allow joint titling
and so we see the the ability to allow
families to stay in communities is that
as a way we can scale way beyond our
core building that's a it's a few of
them
thank you very much for coming um I
worked in the nonprofit sector before
coming to business school and was given
the advice by somebody hmm excuse me at
the Millennium Challenge corporation who
had gone directly from business school
back to the MCC that had to do it over
again she really would have gone to the
private sector before going to the
nonprofit sector and I'm wondering if
you can speak a little bit about
although your intention was clear to go
to to Goldman Sachs what you learned in
all of those years in the private sector
that has made you more effective in your
current role you know it's a really good
question we're actually talking about it
right before this session I don't think
there's a right or wrong rule I think
there are enormous benefits to getting
private sector experience and I think
there are if you were to generalize and
I think they're brilliantly run
nonprofits that are better than in most
companies and then there are a lot of
poorly write off a lot of poorly run
nonprofits still out there likewise
there a lot of well-run companies and
not so well run companies so you need to
choose carefully I think for me my
hypothesis was I would get more
experience faster in the business world
than could take that with me I think
what I would temper that with is the
means to an end I wouldn't take a job
that you really don't want to do just so
you can get to something else because I
think the chances of being successful
aren't as good and I think there are
great individual opportunities if you
take an organization you know takes them
like Muhammad Yunus or if Faisal Abed at
Brock you know if you could work with a
leader like that that would dwarf any
business leader you could ever find in
terms of sort of staggering
entrepreneurial talent but those are but
you have to find the right leader to
attach yourself to so I think it's it's
my view is I would explore both paths if
your passions are leading that way and
then pick you know what the place you
think you're gonna get the highest
learning curve and and the most tangible
experience in the in the shorter term
and then you've got a way in sort of the
golden handcuffs trap of once you know a
lot of people go in saying they're gonna
do this and then they never actually
make the move and you know for 25 years
later they have all these regrets and
they weren't that happy or fulfilled so
it's a you have to be careful
thanks every herd is this is this the
last job I hold it loosely you know the
the person who replaces the founder is
usually the unintentional interim so now
I made it five years so I'm kind of
hoping I'm over the over the beginning
of the curve but what I can honestly say
is this is there's no other job I want
and that's the first time in my my
career where there isn't anything else I
want to do so I hope I get to do this
for a very long time it's it's not as
family-friendly my kids like the church
job a whole lot better and and that's a
that's a real tension of how much travel
I do and kind of keep that and that's
that I think we do annual evaluations as
a family as to whether whether this is
working or not and they really believe
in habitat but but not at all costs so
but I I hope I get to this for a very
long time the board gets that choice
oh thank you fantastic
you